E
THIS WEEK VICE PRESIDENT KHARRIR
ABOUT .E EDSHE APEROTINEIR FIRSE
TWO PEOPLE I HAVENESN
SHOULD NOT RUN AND HE AYE NT SMG
HIM INTO PS GASTS WOULD TU
AN, RIGHT  H
ADUCK BECAU
NTEDCAG THEI I J CARVILLE,
--
ABOUT VAG, TALKING
W AWAY HIS
ARRM.S
AND BRETS IS NICGUY, SHI
O PU T R.
MAYBE 'S THE BEST  COULD
EK.ER THABRETHENS IIG
OFF YOUR CUMN ALL WEEKE.Y ISTHAN
OU SA NC
HEHINKS
S,
ONRS
LESE.
PARTY, NOT JUST E HE'SF TOTTD SS
LLA DISASTUST EC
IS A THAT
AIUT IN CRATIC PARTY MIGHT HIM.
BU WHISPER NOT ALLOWED TO TA ON
-N THE
THD WE NOW LIV AORLD T RUN
PRR ARL, WHERE RS FOR
FOUR YEARS
RA A
I THINK THE PRESIDENIS
SRTY OINT, ULIFA SECOND TERE QU
TH AM SU DEMOCRATS SEE ARGUMENFE
NT
HAS.
IT LERTHT ANRAN LOOKING LIKE B .
>> YOU WROTE IN
COIDERS TO
COER BIDEN'SGED HEALTH, ANG
ONLY PIN'S HANDS AS  PSI WL-ISIA
EVERYBODY REMEMBER
HE SAID I'M NOGOING TO EXPLO
OONH ENCE
EVDALEED.WANTU N THE
CONTEXT OF BUILD B,
BN  S HARMR
PRESTIE LOSE LIMITED
DONE NN  GET
2022?
WOULD BE ASTONISHED THAT
HE'S ABLE TO I>> Reporter: THE O
THIS IS A CNTOFT CRIS THE P
F
IN
HO IT ULN'LESAID I'MO DOHIUTHAV
THE ISE AFFECTING
T GOING TO ALLOW POLITICS  IT.T
THAT AGAIN IS PARTF  O
THE PEON THAT
NEEDS E CAS OUBTWHETHER VICE PRE
HARRIS IA SUITAB
APPA
THE LONGER BIDEN WE SHE ULT NOM
TROUBLESOME FOR THE DEMOCRATIC R
.
>> WEL NUMBERSTHRYN, T UP "THE "
EEN.
RWATER. A 57% DAPTHEL STRE
DO APPRO
BRET JUST REFERE VT KAMALA HARR
WEU DO, I'LL SS TO E PERSON WHO
AI PRESCRIPTIO THE
TH
STATES.CAUSE RIGHT NOE CAN
NINO CAN DO ANNGD
BETOT STEP ON OF
MANTLE RU
SO
ULD CRN'T E AG
THE LEASPOR VICE PRESINT
IN THE 21s
T RUN AGAIN OR IDE THE DEF THATS
THHIANE AR
A WEAPRESIDENT BIDEN ORKE
PRESIDTIINEE HRIDEMOE GOING TO
TO FIND A GOOD
>> IF YO RHT, AN
IS MY INSELECTION
ELAN
TO STEP OUT AND STD  WAYTIAL FOE
MALE PRESIDENT OF THRSONI MELOBG
INAY OF THI DON'T KNOW THAT'S  .
E  BT,
SAY HE P A LONE IN THREE
ARSTAY WHEREOU AND IT UP
ON--'LT
ALOUD.NEVA SAYS, YOUEV THI
YOU'REUSN THE
WHAT'S YER BRET?
THAT AMNGBOUT C
ED.
SUNSHINE IS THE BE
SUNSHINEN A CONVERSATION THATO D
I
ACKNOWLEDGED THIS IS WHAOP
G T.E.
ONE MOREHAVE TIMR,
PUT IT U
DOING SBAD
JOB THAT WE WILL UTH N ICWOULD S
ONSE.
R ,
ZAKAR
.
HE WROTEN ESSAE WASHINGTON POST"
SS GETTING
WE.
>>ALL, D VER RANGEG
HE'S SG  T
AT EDAY,HE
ON BY POPULAR VOTET BY YSFAREED
ON.E RVILLE'SCOMMENE S GOT TO P